I wrote it I sent it I'm cool so a few
years ago in a little apartment in West
Hollywood I was having trouble sleeping
so I've prescribed ambien then I
discovered if I stayed up just a little
bit past when I should I became someone
my friends fondly named Jam be a jam
bein loved to call people she loved to
play her ukulele and sing for people she
loved to eat but in the rare occasions
there wasn't enough food in the fridge
and there was nobody answering their
phone she would send text messages she
would meet in she which hosts at
people's Facebook pages all of these
have been erased in protection of Jamie
but this Facebook post you are something
else
okay just feed me tomorrow morn oh okay
I want to screams it all and set a
pop-tart in my mouth to eat it is TJ re
kW which I think meant can't wait for
this to happen
O's and it will the who who bandit told
you she'd be behind it all
okay bye the who who banded somebody
apparently I tweeted about about 30 to
40 times I have no idea who that is it's
the alternative universe that Jambi and
lives in I've retired from my jam-band
days at least for the time being pro tip
if you've always wondered who your
alter-ego is take ambien
you